so now I want to shift and go over the
two kingdoms of bacterial life in this
diagram we see that there are six
kingdoms overall all life on Earth can
be divided into six kingdoms you
recognize plants animals and fungus at
the top another day we will learn about
Protista Protista are not bacteria
another day we'll learn about them but
look at the two bubbles at the bottom
there's two kingdoms of life called
eubacteria and archaebacteria let's talk
about those next okay so the first
kingdom of life for bacteria that I want
to discuss are called kingdom archaea
bacteria you also might see them called
archaea archaea archaea bacteria same
thing and so what I want to know what I
want you all to know is that these are
the bacteria that live in the extreme
environments of Earth and we're gonna go
over three basic categories of archaea
of archaea bacteria so the picture right
here implies there's the periodic symbol
for oxygen with the line going through
it so this picture implies that some
bacteria can live without oxygen that's
fairly extreme there's not a lot of
organisms on earth that can live without
oxygen this picture right here implies
really hot temperatures there's some
bacteria that can survive in real
extreme heat and this picture right here
I hope like like the picture speaks for
itself implies that some bacteria can
thrive in extreme salty locations so
let's go over the kingdom archaea
bacteria kingdom archaea so three main
categories and again these three
pictures kind of symbol symbolize what's
extreme about the three groups of
archaea of archaea bacteria that I want
to go over
the first one I want to mention are
called methanogens now in the word with
antigen I hope you can see the word
methane so these bacteria have something
to do with methane well what makes them
extreme again is that their organ their
cells that are called anaerobic these
bacteria are anaerobic and that they can
survive without oxygen well the reason
they're called methanogens is because
like their name implies they produce
methane so nathanael genic bacteria are
actually fairly common in the intestines
the intestinal tract the digestive tract
of for instance humans and like the name
methane implies and you can see the
picture right there the person farting
well I think we finally answered an
age-old question of where do farts come
from well farts come from the methane
that is produced in our intestines so
the bacteria that is living inside of
our intestines will produce methane as a
waste product that methane builds up in
our intestines and every now and then we
let go of it in a funny sounding fart so
methanogens that's one of the categories
of our key of archaea bacteria that I
want you all to know about
the second category of Archaea of
archaea bacteria called halophiles
and halophiles what's so extreme about
them is that they thrive in very very
salty environment now you might be
thinking well what's the big deal
there's a lot of life in the salty
oceans
well the saltiness of the oceans is
nowhere near extreme enough to find
these archaea bacteria called halophiles
you think of this saltier locations of
earth other than the oceans the Dead Sea
and the Great Salt Lake in Utah these
are where we find archaea archaea
bacteria called halophiles
they live in extreme salty environments
and if you're asked yourself remember
the memo from earlier in the school year
what normally happens to cells when
they're placed in salt water we'll watch
this animation when cells are normally
placed in salt water through the process
of diffusion they lose water dehydrate
and shrivel up and die but what's
interesting about halophiles is they
thrive in these salty environments way
too salty for fish and other aquatic
organisms
picture along the coast of the Dead Sea
and you can see the white salt that's
been washed up onto the rocks in this
picture here so again the dead sea like
the name implies is a dead body of water
there's really no life in the Dead Sea
with the exception of halophiles HeLa
philic bacteria
and then there's the third category of
Archaea of our key bacteria I want you
to know about called thermophiles now
like the prefix thermo that should imply
heat these bacteria can live in extreme
heats extremely hot environments the
picture shows an underwater what's
called vent an underwater ocean vent and
near the bottom er on the bottom of the
ocean floor there is these little cracks
in the crust and it's called a vent
because there's all this gas spewing and
escaping from the mantle of the earth
and so all these gases and minerals are
spewing out of these what are called
vents and we were shocked to find only
in the 1980s I believe we were shocked
to find that there are thriving
ecosystems down here and and the reason
for that is because of thermophilic
bacteria that can survive in these
extremely hot environments where they're
feeding on the minerals and then other
things eat the bacteria and then you
have a food chain so we were actually
pretty shocked to discover these in the
1980s
we also see in the hot springs of
Yellowstone National Park we see
thermophilic bacteria but these are
three extremely hutton or these are
three extreme groups of life here
methanogens halophiles and thermophiles
so pause the video if you want a little
flow diagram those you that are that
like visual summaries visual diagrams if
I want to pause it and just jot this
down but I'm gonna move on so the other
kingdom of life for bacteria called the
u bacteria these are the modern bacteria
these are the bacteria that are common
to most environments on earth these are
the bacteria that you think of when you
hear the word bacteria and so what I
want you to first mention is that if a
person has a bacterial infection they
have au bacterial infection and the
first step in treating their infection
is to identify is that are they is this
person infected with a gram-negative
infected infection or does the person
have a gram positive infection well
first of all from the picture to the
left we see the words might be a little
small the picture on the left shows a
gram positive bacteria look at the
picture on the right that's a
gram-negative bacteria you can see the
picture on the right bacterial cells
have three layers you can see a layer in
green a thin layer in brown and a layer
on the bottom and orange gram-negative
bacteria are harder to treat because
these bacteria have these three outer
layers that green outer layer called the
capsule harder to treat which means the
person would have to take a stronger
more intense maybe more than one
antibiotic in order to cure their
infection but the gram positive bacteria
you can see that there's only two layers
there's a thick layer and brown and then
there's a layer and orange at the bottom
these are called gram positive and when
you stain them I'll show you what the
Gram stain is in just a moment there's a
test that you can do if a person has an
infection the test is called a Gram
stain and underneath the microscope when
the test is finished the cells will look
either pink or the cells will look
purple that tells you whether or not the
person has a gram negative or a gram
positive infection if a person has a
gram positive infection underneath the
microscope the bacteria will look purple
these bacteria are easier to treat so
you don't have to use
harsh extreme antibiotics and also maybe
they would only maybe have to take only
one antibiotic instead of two or three
different kinds of antibiotics
so here's two pictures there's a pink
picture on top showing gram-negative
there's a purple picture on the bottom
showing gram-positive so one of the
first steps in treating a person with a
bacterial infection is to identify what
kind of bacteria does the person have do
you have a gram-negative infection do
you have a gram positive infection
because the treatment that the person
goes through might be different
depending on whether or not it's
negative or positive so they said these
are some of the common features of you
bacteria you cannot do a Gram stain with
the archaea archaea have different kinds
of cell walls you bacteria have a cell
wall that has a has a few sugars and
amino acids in it called peptidoglycan
peptidoglycan is something that you can
only find in you bacterial cell walls
that's what the Gram stain looks for so
based on how thick the cell wall is
whether or not it stains pink or purple
we can figure out if they're negative or
positive
here's a quick overview a quick summary
of what a Gram stain is so after you
grow a person's bacteria you would stain
the person's bacteria with the objects
in the picture stain the person's
bacteria with a dye called crystal
violet and then another dye called
iodine and then you wash it with alcohol
and then you stain the bacteria with
another dye called safranin and then you
could look at the bacteria underneath
the microscope and you would see that
they would either be pink or purple that
would be the results of your Gram stain
there's another category there's a
category of bacteria I want you to know
about that are called cyanobacteria and
if you look in the pictures all these
cyanobacteria in the pictures are green
that should imply that they do
photosynthesis they have chlorophyll
they can do photosynthesis so
cyanobacteria are autotrophic they do
photosynthesis and they completely
changed the world
watch this cyanobacteria are really
important in terms of evolution here's a
little animation showing the Sun giving
off UV radiation at this time in Earth's
history we're talking three three and a
half billion years ago there was no life
on land because the earth had no ozone
layer the only way for Earth excuse me
the only way for life to survive on land
is underneath the water because water
acts as a shield UV cannot penetrate
very deep into the water so water
provided a home for the first life on
earth and bacteria were the first
bacteria the first anything on earth to
produce oxygen by doing photosynthesis
cyanobacteria because they do
photosynthesis released oxygen the
oxygen is a gas and like all gases the
gases drifts and diffuses and spreads
out and accumulates but this has been
going on for millions and millions and
millions and millions and
millions of years over time watch this
over time the oxygen from cyanobacteria
created a shield created our ozone layer
and now that you have the formation of
an ozone layer look at how the animation
has changed the UV radiation no longer
is striking the ground this was a major
requirement for evolution of life on
Earth because now that you have an ozone
layer blocking UV radiation over of
course millions and millions and
millions of years hundreds of millions
of years life slowly began to evolve on
dry land eventually plants and in
phidian's
and all the life that you see today have
colonized land this could not happen
without the formation of the ozone layer
so cyanobacteria really really changed
the change the earth and the history of
life on Earth forever really important
cyanobacteria and in that sense right
there
so again pause the video if you like
flow diagrams and it's just a little
visual some of the key features of some
of the categories of bacteria so the
last slide I want to talk about is how
our bacterial helpful
well bacteria are incredibly helpful in
nature we just mentioned cyanobacteria
changed the world they created oxygen to
make the ozone layer and here's a little
political cartoon it says here's a to
two bacterias to cyanobacteria cells
talking to one and now they're about 2.5
billion years ago and I know it's a
little blurry so the one on the Left
says if we keep emitting oxygen we could
cause a catastrophic change in the
atmosphere and the cyanobacteria on the
right says nonsense the earth is too big
and we are too insignificant to have any
effect on it drop your cheap alarmism
already well this is kind of a political
cartoon relating to climate change and
global warming there are a small group
of people who argue that humans are too
small of an animal to cause climate
change that climate change is caused by
some other factor there's a small group
of people who think that humans are too
small to have any effect on the earth
and this is kind of a good point the
cartoon is making well bacteria are even
smaller than humans they changed the
earth if bacteria can change the
atmosphere why can't humans granted
bacteria did it over millions and
millions of years but in the past few
centuries humans have been releasing a
lot a lot of pollution into our
atmosphere changing climate around the
world
getting back to bacteria bacteria are
really good decomposers they don't just
recycle carbon I'm only labeling carbon
because carbon is the foundation of
organic molecules decomposes are
incredibly important in recycling
organic molecules carbon-based molecules
proteins carbohydrates lipids nucleic
acids they're incredibly important to
that bacteria are important if you think
back to the ecology chapter on the
nitrogen cycle
here's a picture those little brown
growths you can see these are roots of
plants and there's about fifteen or
twenty little brown growths that you can
see in the picture these are little
clusters of bacteria nitrogen-fixing
bacteria the bacteria will convert
nitrogen into a usable form that the
plant can absorb through the roots and
then nitrogen moves up the food chain
another way that bacteria are really
helpful is just food in the production
of food bacteria do a process called
fermentation and we use fermentation to
create various kinds of food and here's
a small list of foods created from
bacterial fermentation might recognize
some of these as maybe a favorite snack
of yours I'm going through a phase right
now where I really like Greek yogurt
bacteria have been used to make
antibiotics now most back to air excuse
me most antibiotics most antibiotics
that we have come from fungus but some
do actually come from other bacteria
some bacteria make antibiotics to kill
other bacteria if you're a bacteria and
can kill your competition you're more
likely to survive and reproduce and
we've learned that some bacteria
actually make antibiotics which we can
then give to people who have infections
and we're also using bacteria in
industry the picture on the bottom shows
a couple individuals cleaning up after
an oil spill they're spraying you can
see a mist being sprayed on these rocks
after an oil spill there is a species of
bacteria that will literally feed on the
petroleum of the oil spill and break
down the oil into less harmful materials
so we're using bacteria to help clean up
oil spills and environmental disasters
we're also using bacteria to produce
fuel biofuels if you've ever heard of a
gasoline called e85 it stands for 85%
ethanol ethanol is an alcohol that we
can use to run automobiles and it comes
from bacteria fermenting corn and when
we use bacteria to ferment corn we make
this this alcohol called ethanol which
we can use to fuel automobiles it's it's
a lot cleaner than burning gasoline so
there's all kinds of useful benefits of
bacteria they're not all negative even
though the word bacteria might scare us
because we think of germs and disease a
lot of bacteria
very helpful
even though a lot of bacteria are very
helpful here are some very gross
pictures of disease that bacteria can
cause first of all here's a healthy
picture of teeth and healthy picture of
gums well the next picture this picture
shows a dental problem called gingivitis
you can see the gums are a little red
and puffy well that's because the gums
are infected they're a little red and
puffy they're swollen gums and they're
infected with bacteria now if you go to
the dentist your dentist will see this
and you'll start the cleaning process in
order to in order to correct this but
ultimately the problem could get even
worse and could lead to something called
periodontitis look at this the gums are
really red really puffy you can see the
plaque in between the teeth and it
almost looks like the teeth are growing
but that's not the case it's the gums
that are shrinking and when the gums
recede or when the gums shrink it
exposes more tooth and eventually if
this is not treated it can lead to
what's called advanced to periodontitis
look at how gross this is you can see
this person really has infected gums and
so this person really is gonna need some
intense dental care but I hope you see
the moral of the story is to brush your
teeth floss your teeth and rinse your
teeth on a very regular basis
one of the concerns with bacteria of
course is bacterial resistance and these
cute cartoons you've seen them before in
the upper left-hand corner when you take
an antibiotic most bacteria die in the
upper right hand corner however some
bacteria survive notice how the
bacterias were in a helmet that's
symbolic of a bacteria is resistant to
an antibiotic in the lower left hand
corner the strong bacteria reproduce
that reproduction process is called
binary fission and in the lower right
hand corner when the disease has now
returned you take an antibiotic again
but look only bacteria with helmets are
left the bacteria has become resistant
so the antibiotic just doesn't work
anymore this is a very serious concern
so make sure if you have to take an
antibiotic you're using it properly
okay so now that we've reached the end
go ahead and pause the video and try to
answer these questions on a piece of
paper and if you want me to check your
answers before class one day come on in
before school come on in after school
I'll be happy to check your answers for
accuracy so go ahead and pause the video
and and do your best on these good luck